Russia has stepped up its missile
attacks on Ukraine a number of
explosions have been heard in the
capital well let's bring in Harry
Fawcett he joins us now live from Kiev
Harry are we seeing a renewed attack now
on the capital
yes we are this is the third Monday in
October that there have been a series of
such strikes here uh in the Ukrainian
Capital uh they started a couple of
hours ago loud explosions heard
particularly to the north of Kiev the
government is saying that 40 strikes
have been carried out on Kiev and there
have been images as well of some
interceptions or at least the use of uh
anti-missile systems as well and the
authorities here are saying that there
have been partial power outages as a
result it seems to be another attack on
infrastructure water shortages as well
the mayor is saying that otherwise
services are operating as normally as
possible and there have been reports
from elsewhere in the country as well uh
kharkiv the Metro stopped working at
least for some time in the chakasi
region in zapparesia partial power
outages there as well and about 30-40
minutes ago lots of phones were buzzing
in in this building and presumably
around the country country with an
extreme emergency alert that's a new
system that they've been testing
recently when there is a sort of a
national scale emergency level attack so
reports of further launches as well so
yes it is another wide scale attack it
seems being launched on this Monday by
Russia and it comes just a couple of
days after the the Drone attack that
Russia says was carried out by Ukraine
against its Naval vessels in Crimea
Harry Fawcett they're live for us on the
ground in Kiev thanks so much Harry and
stay safe
well as Harry referred to there let's
move on to talking about those civilian
cargo ships the UN coordinator for the
Black Sea grain deal is saying those
ships can never be a military Target or
held hostage it comes after Russia
decided to pull out of the U.N brokered
grain deal the UN takier and Ukraine
have all agreed on a plan to now allow
14 ships transferring Grant to leave
Turkish Waters Ukraine says a total of
218 vessels are effectively blocked
Moscow says it withdrew from the
three-month-old agreement after an
attack on its Black Sea Fleet